this is getting vulnerable hey everyone
i'm abby sharpe welcome to abby's
kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by let's get
checked and we are back with part seven
of our review of jaclyn hill's wellness
journey but first let me tell you about
my sponsor let's get checked so i get a
lot of questions every day about whether
or not a person needs a certain
supplement and my answer to that
question is always it depends there's no
for sure way for me to actually know if
you need vitamin d or b12 or like
thyroid support or whatever without data
from a credible test so let's get
checked is finally making professional
health testing more accessible and easy
for you at home with their wide range of
wellness tests the way it works is you
choose your test online and it's
delivered to you the next day then you
collect your sample return it with the
prepaid shipping label and you get your
confidential results within two to five
days and the key here is that you don't
have to interpret them yourself a
physician will review your results and a
nurse will contact you for a virtual
consultation and if a prescription is
warranted then of course the doctor can
write it right there but let's get
checked labs are clia approved and cap
accredited which are the highest level
of accreditation so you can rest assured
that your results are reliable so if you
want to get tested at home use my promo
code abby sharp for 30 off using my link
below okay so basically we are back
again to revisit jaclyn's wellness saga
oh boy but if you missed my most recent
video you can check that out right here
so today we're going to be taking a look
at jaclyn's february 21st video opening
up about my biggest struggle and of
course you can pause the screen or look
at my description to check out my
general disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating also a note that this is a unique
video in the series because jacqueline
is focusing more on her struggles with
alcohol use so another major trigger
warning that we will be discussing
alcohol use disorder and i will also be
leaving some resources down in the
description below if you are currently
struggling and need some support also
reminder that i'm not a therapist or a
substance abuse expert but i will be
speaking from my own perspective as a
registered dietitian and if you are not
already subscribed hit that subscribe
button and follow me on tik tok and
instagram at abby's kitchen all right
let's get into it i'm doing um a therapy
called neurofeedback i've talked about
it before and i go several days a week
i've been doing so much better therapy
is definitely helping me i have not
cared about my diet at all you guys at
all uh when i first started this i was
183 and then i dropped all the way down
to 170 and now i'm back to 175. okay so
when we last caught up with jacqueline
she put her weight loss journey on hold
to focus on her mental health and
therapy which made sense to me because
food issues are often used as
ineffective coping mechanisms when
mental or emotional needs are just not
being met and often this preoccupation
with weight and food tends to kind of
soften when we learn better coping
strategies and remember this is the same
girl who spiraled after a minor and very
normal two pound increase on the scale
so the fact that she's talking about her
weight regain with like a smile on her
face feels like a huge breakthrough to
me and i am just so very proud of her i
became very dependent on alcohol i use
alcohol to cope with anxiety and as my
anxiety has been getting so much better
i have been able to cut back on alcohol
which has been amazing okay so not
unlike when people use food to deal with
negative emotions when alcohol becomes
like a primary coping mechanism it does
risk becoming a serious problem not
surprisingly it's quite common for
anxiety disorders and alcohol use
disorders to co-occur with research
suggesting that up to 50
of folks receiving treatment for alcohol
use disorder also suffer from an anxiety
disorder and according to some research
drinking to cope among folks with
anxiety may actually result in a
five-fold increase for developing an
alcohol use disorder within three months
and fyi i'm using alcohol use disorder
because that is the official term for
like alcohol abuse or alcohol dependence
but it's also worth noting that alcohol
doesn't cure anxiety it actually often
creates like a bit of a cyclical effect
that causes your anxiety to actually
feel worse which then increases your
desire to drink and it can kind of
spiral from there but as is the case
with a turbulent relationship with food
an unhealthy relationship with alcohol
often also has a root cause and i'm so
happy to see her working through those
root causes in therapy so bad for me
mentally physically for inflammation
people have their vices and i know for
me at one point my advice was coloring
like just adult coloring books was just
helping me so much and that's how i was
coping and i need to find things like
that again whether it be working out or
going on walks or whatever it is okay so
i applaud jacqueline for recognizing
this within herself and for sharing it
with the world and i am not an
addictions counselor again but
acknowledging the problem is a really
important first step it is very hard to
take the next step to actually take
action to change behaviors if you're not
convinced that they're problematic in
the first place so to help better
support this process it's essential that
jaclyn begin to explore other coping
mechanisms for her anxiety and all of
the strategies that she mentioned like
adult coloring books walks spending time
with jordan etc are all super great we
also know that lifestyle behaviors like
quality sleep meditation yoga and
adequate nutrition can also help to
reduce anxiety
extreme dieting on the other hand is
often just like adding kindle to the
fire when we under eat our cortisol
levels increase because under eating is
an actual physical stressor on the body
which research suggests can actually
exacerbate the effects of anxiety so i
am so glad that we put the weight loss
leg of her journey on the back burner
can i start taking care of myself
because we need kids we need a family
and i need to fit into my dream dress so
amongst all this i need to get that bod
i need to get that bot okay never mind
and it's gone now i am all for self-care
and doing what you can to help support
your health and fertility if you're
preparing yourself to conceive but
didn't she just say that she stopped
caring about like the weight loss diet
the devil works hard folks but diet
culture
works harder get your [ __ ] ass up and
work and unfortunately the wedding body
is one of diet culture's easiest targets
and while my professional opinion is
that the wedding body should really not
be a priority right now at all if
there's also a goal for optimizing
health for fertility we definitely need
to tread lightly here we do know that
extreme restriction and weight loss can
and does negatively impact fertility so
if baby making is the goal getting the
alcohol intake to a healthier place is
key
but not at the expense necessarily of
getting an adequate nutrition typically
before i would go to a new place because
i have such bad social anxiety i would
have a drink before i leave like not
trying to get drunk or anything like
that but just like one shot enough to
take like the edge off i'm gonna go try
a new place we've never been to before
and i'm not going to try to
self-medicate myself with anything i'm
just going and if i get anxious i get
anxious and we'll work through it we ate
and i just got so anxious that we had to
leave i just like out of nowhere just
got so anxious like all of a sudden the
music like i feel like everything became
overstimulated ugh
i am getting secondhand anxiety watching
this as i can heavily relate to that
feeling of like stimulation overload and
needing to gtfo asap but according to
the research about 20 of folks with
social anxiety disorder also suffer from
alcohol use disorder and while a lot of
people can safely have like a little bit
of alcohol to calm their nerves on
occasion it does come down to frequency
dependency and the reinforcing powers of
avoiding situations without a drink so
folks like me and maybe jacqueline who
struggle with anxiety often make
associations between a general anxiety
trigger or like a negative experience
and a full-blown fear a little more
readily than those without anxiety so
the easiest thing to do is obviously to
avoid the discomfort preemptively which
actually only reinforces and strengthens
our fears as kind of like a fact it
often becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
so what jaclyn did here is what we call
exposure therapy and it's not
surprisingly been shown to be a very
effective treatment strategy for social
anxiety basically you repeatedly expose
yourself to the situation that triggers
the anxiety and the idea is that after a
while of repeated exposure your reaction
tends to decline the same strategy is
often implemented in eating disorder
recovery as a way to normalize fear
foods and in insomnia therapy to
desensitize yourself to different sleep
habits but because it's obviously really
scary to face your fears head on it can
often be helpful to have a few healthy
coping strategies in your back pocket to
help ease the nerves so things like
breathing and relaxation techniques
calming tea like a soothing playlist or
a safe support person by your side so
i'm really really proud of jacqueline
for making this sleep it's been a solid
nine days of me cutting back on my
drinking and no longer using it as a
medicine no longer using it to
self-medicate i have not given into it
really well there was yeah i did once
once i took a i had a quick drink when i
was super stressed out earlier today
it's been really hard but i have to say
overcoming it feels so good i'm not
gonna drink right now i'm done like i'm
so sick of it like almost like a manic
way like i i'm not doing this anymore i
don't care how bad my anxiety is really
working and focusing on anxiety has been
a very big thing for me so it sounds to
me like jaclyn is trying to abstain from
alcohol altogether not unlike her very
kind of regimented restrictive approach
to her diet in the past now i'm not
suggesting that jaclyn has like an ed
but it is worth pointing out that it's
common for folks with complicated
histories with food to kind of play out
the same types of restrictive or binge
symptoms in other areas of their life so
we call these life symptoms so for
example folks who have binge eating
tendencies with food may also find that
they binge on things like shopping or
relationships or alcohol usually there's
a root cause and the substance or
activity is just a bit of a distraction
now a lot of people challenge me on
intuitive eating saying well you
wouldn't tell an alcoholic to health
drink in moderation so why is it okay to
tell somebody to have you know less
nutritious food in moderation and i
think this question is often bound up in
a lot of ignorance of the intuitive
eating model but the major differences
here are twofold one the concept of food
addiction is very much contested and not
confirmed by the data even though of
course people may feel addicted to food
but alcohol use disorder is confirmed by
data and two we can abstain from alcohol
if it's not adding to our life but we
obviously can't abstain from food
alcohol also can actually make listening
to our body cues a lot more difficult
but eating can make listening to our
body cues more clear i also spoke to my
sister dr skye fitzpatrick who is a
clinical psychologist and she said that
a lot of clinicians support a relapse
prevention model for folks with alcohol
use disorder where the goal is to reduce
use or make it safer rather than abstain
completely and this is not unlike my
approach with triggering foods now it's
important to note that for some folks
abstinence from alcohol is absolutely
what's going to work best and again that
is still 100 compatible with intuitive
eating because alcohol is not an
essential substance like food so this
might work for jaclyn but i also worry
about her falling into the same kind of
abstain binge regret repeat cycle that
she has done in the past with food so in
all these situations there needs to be
like a personal risk benefit analysis
done with a therapy team i just let the
craving pass and things like ice cream
helps
and i don't care if i put on a little
weight right now i don't love that idea
but if it means i'm gonna get away from
alcohol and this relationship that i
have with it i don't really care if i
put on a few pounds in the meantime
because i think that that's way more
important than anything else so i am so
relieved to hear that her weight loss
goals are kind of taking a back backseat
but i do caution about kind of swapping
one numbing strategy for another i think
it'd be a very different story if jaclyn
had a more stable relationship with food
but given her strong emotional eating
tendencies in the past we don't
necessarily want you know ice cream to
become the only coping alternative to
alcohol and this is not to say that she
shouldn't eat ice cream when she's
feeling it everyone should eat ice cream
when they're feeling it
but it comes down to the intention
behind it is she eating ice cream
because that's what's going to truly
bring her emotional satisfaction or is
she eating ice cream as a way to
distract and numb herself from some of
the tough emotions or to like keep her
mouth busy when she wants a glass of
wine now i appreciate her prioritizing
her health over weight loss goals in
this scene but two minutes ago she was
also going off about getting her wedding
bod so as usual we're getting a little
bit of a murky picture of intentions now
my main concern is that while she's
giving herself a bit of a permission
slip to gain some weight right now when
she does pivot back to weight loss for
maybe her wedding and fitting into the
wedding dress i'm worried that any
weight gained may trigger another
downward spiral so it's important that
those emotional regulation strategies
are in place now to better support any
ups and downs that may arise in the
future the stronger i'm being and the
less i drink and the more i fight
through and allow myself just to feel
anxiety the less i have anxiety this
past week which is crazy as someone who
has lived experience with anxiety my
whole life i can say that feeling the
feelings is very hard and extremely
uncomfortable but as they say you often
gotta feel it to heal it and just as i
mentioned with exposure therapy the more
you just kind of sit with the discomfort
the less power those feelings will own i
haven't cut it out completely i want you
guys to be aware of that like i have not
gotten to the point where i'm like i'm
not drinking for the next 30 days or 60
days or 90 days or a year whatever it
may be it's not like that i am just
allowing myself to drink in moderation
when it's appropriate and i'm not using
it to self-medicate you know what i'm
saying so at my engagement party i had
three drinks while i was okay so it
looks like we're pivoting to a more
relapse prevention model and perhaps
jaclyn has kind of realized that in the
past she's put restricted food on a
pedestal which only serve to make it
more desirable in the end it also seems
that she's starting to distinguish
between her intention behind the
drinking so whether it's for social
reasons or to cope with stress and the
same intention analysis can be applied
to her relationship with food is this
for nourishment and satisfaction is this
an emotional choice or is it a means of
restriction or to satisfy ravenous
hunger so whether we're talking about
food or alcohol we can apply some of
those same intuitive approaches from a
place of self-care not self-control
since i cut back so much on alcohol i
decided i'm not gonna focus on my diet
because that's not what's important
right now like cutting out the alcohol
is so much more important so i've been
eating whatever i want whatever i want
i've been craving sugar like you have no
idea and it turns into sugar in your
body so when i cut out the alcohol you
know it's like 11 o'clock at night and
i'm like i want a reese's like i
want an ice cream bar and i let myself
have it because i'm like i'm not going
to deprive myself of that too you know
one step at a time i'm being realistic
okay fact check alcohol itself doesn't
convert into sugar in the body but it
does cause blood sugars to rise a little
bit more so obviously if the alcohol is
mixed with like a sugar sweetened drink
like soda or juice but then after the
liver processes the booze you actually
end up with very low blood sugar levels
and this is sometimes why we feel kind
of shaky and ravenous in the morning
after drinking good morning
my guess is that jaclyn's sugar craving
has more to do with her emotional eating
tendencies and kind of getting that
dopamine hit from sugar in the absence
of alcohol some may call an experience
like this like a transfer addiction
where one coping mechanism like sugar is
replaced for another like alcohol i
weighed myself today and i've lost three
and a half pounds in the last three
weeks and that's me eating so much junk
goes to show how much denial i was in
like the inflammation that was in my
blood work last year was so high and i
just didn't want to admit that it was
alcohol it was so much easier to change
my diet and get my ass on the treadmill
than it was to admit i have an alcohol
problem so there is a positive
correlation between weight gain and
alcohol intake and there are a few
explanations for why this is for one
alcohol is more energy dense than carbs
or protein and provides about seven
calories per gram and this of course
would be increased when mixed with
something like juice or soda etc two
alcohol intake can also disrupt sleep
quality which can then increase appetite
the next day three chronic alcohol
consumption can increase inflammation
and water retention and lastly alcohol
often leads to disinhibition so we often
end up eating more now i imagine it took
a long time to get to this breakthrough
so my hope for jacqueline is that she
continues to develop her sense of
self-awareness emotional support and
coping strategies for her anxiety so
that she can not only positively impact
a relationship with food and alcohol but
also manage any other future life
symptoms that are thrown her way so on
that note that is all that i have for
you guys today thank you again to let's
get checked for sponsoring if you like
this video be sure to give it a thumbs
up leave me a comment below on what
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]